-Welcome back.
-I'm upset.
-Upset about?
-That you would have me on
the show with Fred Savage,
for crying out loud.
-Why --
-I have beef with
Fred Savage.
-What is your beef
with Fred Savage?
-I have this rare moment.
I get to go to Comic-Con.
-Yes.
-This was amazing for me,
because --
-This is out in San Diego.
-I literally became
a Pac-10 football player
just to compensate for
the fact that I'm a huge nerd.
-Gotcha, right.
-Just want to have some
balance in my life.
And I'm walking through
crowded Comic-Con,
and somebody comes up to me,
"Mr. Booker,
Fred Savage would like you
to have this."
And I turn around, and it'
a pair of sunglasses.
And I'm like, who does this gu
think he is?
He's literally giving me shade
And --
[ Laughter ]
Or maybe he thinks
he's such a big star --
I've never met the guy -- that I
need sunglasses to view him.
-Wow.
-And so I look around.
I go, "Where is Fred Savage?
They said, "Well, he would
like to see you."
And I tried to find him, but I
couldn't connect with the guy.
So, I just see him...
-Wow.
-...as one of these stars --
-How do you think I feel?
I've met him multiple times.
He's never given me anything
[ Laughter ]
You should feel lucky
that you were --
-Well, I thought we were going
to have a moment backstage
but he did not even --
-He didn't even want to see you.
So you did go to Comic-Con
These are not the sunglasses
he gave you, right?
-Those were not.
-Okay, got it.
-Those are virtual -- that i
actually our taxpayer dollars.
-Okay.
-That's NASA.
-Uh-huh.
-And they were showing peopl
a virtual reality of what it
would be like to be on Mars.
-Okay.
-And I got very afraid
that I might have
a Matt Damon moment there.
-Yeah.
-It was so real,
I thought, "Maybe I'll get
left behind."
-Are there times as you've bee
running for President
that you've thought,
"Mars doesn't sound so bad"?
[ Laughter ]
-There's been times
metaphorically
I'd like to send
our President --
-You -- this is a true story
that you have.
This says, "The nerd gene is
strong in you."
-Yes. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I think that's one
of the nice things.
-Yeah. I am...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I -- and I just want
to say this --
I had the privilege
just this week of getting
some campaign support
from Leonard Nimoy's widow
Susan Nimoy.
So, it's like, for me --
-That's very nice.
-These are the --
these are the --
to have her on my team --
-And I do think it's important
to note that I think that
even 10, 20 years ago, someone
who was sort of out as a ner
would have no chance running
for President in this country.
I think everything has changed
for the better
insofar that people who like
things like superheroes
and science fiction --
-Yes, yes.
-...this is now fully accepted
-We are living the conclusio
of the movie
"Revenge of the Nerds,"
where it's now --
-Yes.
-...it is now very cool
to be a nerd.
In fact, I try to hide the fac
that I was an All-American
football player.
-Yeah.
-That does not get me anywhere
-Nobody likes that anymore
Yeah.
-Nobody cares about that.
[ Laughter ]
-But I do -- you were
talking about Fred Savage
showing you
a little bit of shade.
We're about -- I think about ten
days out from the next round
of Democratic debates.
-Yes, yes.
One of the meme-able moments..
-Yes.
-...from the first night
of the debates...
-Meme-able moment.
-Beto O'Rourke, he started
speaking Spanish,
and you were caught on camera...
-Yes. Yes.
-And that looks like --
-Yes.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yes. Yes.
-Now I think --
-Yes.
-I think
the technical term there
might be side-eye.
-Ye-- yes, yes.
-Now I would imagine
in the moment
you were probably not
aware that this was going to b
one of the takeaways
of that debate.
-Yeah. The coaching I got
from my campaign team --
these are really incredibl
professionals -- was,
"Don't do that again."
[ Laughter ]
-So we should not look
for a return --
-No, no, no, you will not se
the return of the side-eye
unless -- I'll be standing
next to Joe Biden this time.
-Okay, gotcha.
-So it depends on what --
-Well, that wasn't really fair
because I also feel like
they must tell you --
you know, obviously,
you're watching
and you want to be respectfu
and you want to look
at somebody,
and you did not know
you were in a three shot there
-No, I did not.
-And now you'll learn,
especially right next
to Joe Biden.
You might -- a two shot's
easier than a three shot.
So you got to be real careful.
-You're a few shots
beyond me right now.
[ Laughter ]